recent months have seen their fair share  of turmoil around the globe but one  thing should be crystal clear American  leadership is the one constant in an  uncertain world it's America our troops  our diplomats that lead the fight to  degrade and ultimately destroy the  terrorist group known as ISIL it's  America our doctors our scientists are  know how that leads the fight to contain  and combat the Ebola epidemic in West  Africa it's America our colleges our  graduate schools our unrivaled private  sector that attracts so many people to  our shores to study and start businesses  and tackle some of the most challenging  problems in the world